defending the world's largest network
against constantly evolving cyber
threats has driven us to develop
advanced tools to help keep us and our
customers ahead I'm gonna go into detail
on four ways we can help defend your
business critical data and applications
from some of today's biggest security
threats let's start with ransomware
recent Google research shows cyber
thieves have made at least twenty five
million dollars from ransomware in the
last two years and this is expected to
grow to protect ourselves and our
customers from this and other types of
malware we've built multiple layers of
protection most of which are automated
and available to our customers by
default first our global visibility and
the malicious sites and content makes
detection highly effective if you're a
gmail user we prevent thousands of
malicious attachments from ever reaching
inboxes if something does reach your
inbox Google Safe Browsing and our
Chrome browser protects users by
identifying dangerous links in email and
showing warnings if users click on them
this stops access to any web sites which
are known to distribute malware if
you've ever been blocked from a site
like this you've experienced Safe
Browsing at work every minute of the day
we find and label another malware site
and warned users have suspected malware
hundreds of times in Google Drive all
files undergo a malware scan prior to
any download or sharing drive also
stores files in non-executable formats
which prevent ransomware from
propagating our Chrome operating system
continually updates automatically
ensuring it's highly resistant to
malware compromised applications our
sandbox to prevent harm to the host
machine often these features remove any
need for anti-malware or antivirus
software and at the mobile device level
every single day we check the health of
over 400 million Android devices and
scan over 6 billion mobile applications
downloaded Android phones to make sure
they're not infected Safe Browsing
protects over 2 billion mobile phones
laptops tablets and other devices which
use Google software
now let's look at denial of service
attacks a distributed denial of service
attack or DDoS attack is an attempt to
make an online service unavailable by
overwhelming it with traffic from
multiple sources they can have a huge
impact of business's own aren't
adequately prepared as a Google cloud
customer you were protected by default
to this type of attack as the scale of
our infrastructure enables us to simply
absorb many of them for context a huge
attack last year had a strength of
around one terabit per second the whole
internet has a bisection bandwidth of
200 terabytes per second now when you
compare this to a single Google Data
Center which has a bisection bandwidth
of 13 hundred terabytes per second you
can see we have built-in level of
internal capacity multiple times that of
any traffic load we anticipate when
there is an attack we have time to
isolate it and address it but we don't
stop there in Google cloud platform
customers benefit directly from our
central dose mitigation service that
provides an additional multi tier multi
layer protections and further reduces
the risk to services running behind our
Google front end when the system detects
an attack is taking place it can
configure load balancers to drop or
throttle traffic associated with the
attack so what do we do to prevent data
breaches it's critical to know where
sensitive data is but that can be
difficult in complex systems at Google
we encrypt our customers data in
different ways depending upon what the
data is doing and all of this happens by
default with no user action required
data is potentially vulnerable to
unauthorized access as it travels across
the internet or within networks because
it's linked to most ISPs in the world
Google's private global network helps to
improve the security of data in transit
by limiting the hops across the public
Internet any data traveling from a
customer's device to Google's cloud is
protected using HTTPS or TLS limiting
opportunities for traffic to be
intercepted in fact Google is the first
major cloud provider to enable this by
default at Google we encrypt our
customers data in different ways
depending upon what the data is doing
whether it is stored in a database or in
transit to and from Google it all
happens by default with no user action
required data is encrypted at the
hardware layer inside of our data center
that way it can only be decrypted in our
cloud on another verified Google machine
when it's stored data is broken up into
numerous different shards and sent to
different servers this guards against
hackers and it's good for disaster
recovery and business continuity
insuring against natural disasters
unplanned downtime or equipment failures
when you call up a document in Google
Drive for example the document is
recalled from all of its storage points
decrypted and reassembled in the blink
of an eye additionally as customers you
have the option of managing encryption
keys with our cloud key management
service or even supplying your own
encryption keys if you're looking for
additional granular levels of control
data loss prevention is an effective
technology to ensure that sensitive data
doesn't leave the organization or get
accessed by people that it's not
intended for in Google cloud platform
and G suite users can find and secure
sensitive content minimize what data
they collect and implement data
governance policies our DLP API helps
you to manage and run analytics on your
cloud data without introducing
additional risk to your organization it
provides fast scalable classification
and optional redaction for over 40
sensitive data types like credit card
numbers names passport numbers and more
as you can see here it can be used to
automatically classify or redact
sensitive data from a text stream before
you write it to disk generate logs or
perform analysis on it finally let's
look at an attack that many
organizations are concerned about
phishing according to the 2017 Verizon
data breach investigations report 90% of
all incidents and breaches that involve
social actions by external actors
include fishing everyone is overwhelmed
with email and it just takes one person
to hardly click on a rogue message to
have a fishing incident
if you've ever seen an email that looks
like this you'll know what I'm talking
about our first defense is to prevent
phishing emails from ever reaching
people
Gmail filtering blocks the majority of
malicious email and our global
visibility across users makes this
visibility highly effective Gmail also
restricts the use of file types that
carry a high potential for security
risks even inside a compressed file if a
malicious link gets through the next
layer of protection is Safe Browsing in
Chrome which prevents users from
visiting known phishing websites where
their credentials can be stolen or
malware installed on their device then
even if an attacker manages to gain the
credentials they were looking for such
as a username and password we provide
two-factor verification and security
keys which make the use of compromised
credentials extremely difficult instead
of entering a unique code as a second
factor at sign-in security key sends us
cryptographic proof that users on a
legitimate Google site and that they
have their security keys with them a
physical action is required and since
most hijackers are remote their efforts
can be thwarted because they cannot get
possession of the security key to
increase control further businesses can
take advantage of security key
enforcement which allows Google Cloud
administrators to enable 2-step
verification that forces users to use
security keys as the second factor
security keys work with Google accounts
of no charge but you'll need to buy a
compatible USB device directly from a
u2f participating vendor finally if a
Chromebook somehow gets compromised as a
result of a phishing attack it can
quickly and easily be restored to a
known good state as you can see we're
constantly innovating for our customers
to help prevent compromises all across
the stack compared to legacy security
approaches using Google cloud means that
typical deployment is faster and scale
much more easily Automation is easier
functionality evolves and improves more
quickly and often the cost of
acquisition is lower